ahora que sabemos lo que es un ángulo
pensemos en cómo podemos medirlo y ya
vimos una pista de una manera de medir
un ángulo en el vídeo anterior
dijimos que bueno este ángulo de acá x
de zeta se ve más abierto que el ángulo
de hace se ve más cerrado así que la
medida del ángulo x y esta será más
grande que la del ángulo de ac y esa es
la forma en la que pensamos medir los
ángulos pero lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es encontrar un modo más preciso
para medir estos ángulos lo que he
dibujado aquí abajo
ese semicírculo que es muy similar a una
herramienta que ustedes pueden conseguir
en cualquier papelería o tienda de
artículos escolares es para medir
ángulos y este se llama transportador
así que a esto le llamamos transportador
transportados
qué hacemos con ellos y ustedes pueden
construir uno usando un pedazo de papel
y haciendo divisiones en un medio
círculo como vemos acá dividiéndolo en
180 divisiones iguales una para cada
grado toman la mitad de un círculo lo
dividen en 180 secciones que aquí
estamos marcando más o menos en decenas
cada una de esas rayas son 10 grados o
10 secciones y lo que se hace para
cualquier ángulo dado es que ponemos
esto en uno de los lados del ángulo voy
a dibujar aquí dentro de mi
transportador este ángulo x y z voy a
coincidir hacer coincidir el vértice y
dentro de este punto el centro de mi
transportador aquí voy a dibujar mi
vértice y voy a hacer coincidir que este
eje que está en el cero coincida con uno
de los lados de este ángulo por ejemplo
con el lado hoy me quedo con el lado de
zeta
voy a dibujar este otro lado pues igual
como lo tenemos en este ángulo tratando
de ser lo más precisa posible
el lado de x va a estar más o menos
por acá
este es el lado de x de este ángulo x y
z y vemos que el transportador este lado
del ángulo queda más o menos por acá
esta es la marca de los 70 por lo que
está bueno esta otra marca son de los 80
aquí este ángulo coincide
aproximadamente con los 77 y como nos
comentaba cada una de las divisiones de
estas 180 divisiones del transportador
es un grado y nosotros especificamos los
grados dibujando una bolita que hacia
arriba como si escribiéramos la
temperatura ambiente así que la medida
uso esta m para indicar la medida del
ángulo x y z aunque normalmente usamos
el ángulo y el igual pero esto es un
poquito más formal en usar la m va a ser
igual a 77 grados y aquí tenemos la
medida de este primer ángulo
los grados no son la única manera de
medir ángulos cualquier cosa que mira
esta abertura servirá para medir ángulos
cuando estudian trigonometría verán que
se miden ángulos no sólo en grados sino
en algo llamados radiales pero eso lo
veremos en otra ocasión ahora miremos
este otro ángulo de hace de nuevo voy a
poner el vértice y voy a reemplazar aquí
en este punto del transportador en lugar
de tener el vértice y lo voy a quitar un
poco de acá
y aquí voy a poner mi vértice
de este ángulo
algo que coincida este lado del ángulo
con el lado que tiene marcado el 0 en el
transportador lo hago así voy a
sobreescribir en éste ahora aquí tengo
mi lado
y aquí arriba voy a dibujar este lado
más o menos más o menos por
este es más cerrado ok
ahora este es mi lado a b
de mi ángulo vi ac y este lado apunta
hacia esta marca de los 30 grados en el
transportador así que podemos decir que
la medida del ángulo base es igual a 30
grados y como estamos viendo aquí 77
grados es mayor que 30 grados esta
abertura de este ángulo es más grande
que esta abertura de acá por lo que
estas mediciones coinciden en general
hay algunos ángulos interesantes de
conocer si tenemos un ángulo de cero
grados vamos a tener un ángulo cerrado
conforme nos vamos alejando de este
punto pues nuestro ángulo se va a abrir
más hasta que llegue el punto en el que
uno de los lados va a estar horizontal
por ejemplo comenzamos aquí con nuestro
lado del ángulo se va a abrir se va a
abrir se va a abrir hasta que llegue al
punto en el que su lado terminal va a
estar completamente vertical
como es este caso
aquí tenemos un ángulo de 90 grados o lo
podemos ver incluso así se los puedo
dibujar de esta manera
y si ustedes los rotan este ángulo para
que coincida con la forma del
transportador a la posición del
transportador van a ver que esto queda
en los 90 grados
este es un ángulo muy especial y aparece
muchas veces en los ejercicios de
geometría y trigonometría e incluso hay
una palabra especial para referirse a un
ángulo de 90 grados ángulo recto
ángulo recto
e incluso tiene un símbolo muy
particular para denominar un ángulo de
90 grados lo que hacemos es dibujar una
pequeña pues digamos como cajita aquí
dentro del ángulo de manera que si esto
lo rotamos uno de estos lados va a
quedar horizontal y el otro va a quedar
vertical esto es un ángulo de 90 grados
un ángulo recto y si seguimos abriendo
el ángulo cada vez más llegaremos a un
punto en donde nuestro ángulo va a lucir
así voy a poner otro color un azul claro
si tenemos nuestro ángulo que inicia acá
en azul clarito y lo vamos abriendo todo
todo todo todo hasta que llegue al punto
en el que queda así con la marca de los
180 grados pues vamos a tener una línea
recta un ángulo que mide 180 grados lo
podemos llamar ángulo ya no un ángulo
que luce algo así como
una línea recta se le llama
al ángulo
la flechita bien puesta si este ángulo
lo llamáramos este vértice x este lado z
y este lado y diríamos que la medida del
ángulo z x sería igual a 180 grados
un ángulo ya no podemos ir aún más lejos
dando toda la vuelta al círculo para
llegar a 360 grados y continuar dando
vueltas y vueltas veremos más al
respecto cuando veamos trigonometría hay
un par de cosas más que quiero presentar
la acción de este vídeo y son palabras
especiales y hablaremos más de ellas en
otros vídeos pero si un ángulo es menor
a 90 grados por ejemplo estos dos
ángulos con los que iniciamos este vídeo
estos dos ángulos que son menores a 90
grados los llamamos agudos ángulos
agudos escribimos bien agudos los
ángulos que no son agudos y que también
tienen una palabra para denominar se
lucen así van a tener su lado más o
menos así mayor a 90 grados
estos ángulos que son mayores a 90
grados los llamamos ángulos obtusos ese
es un ángulo obtuso
obtuso
yo me acuerdo que los ángulos son agudos
cuando tienen la forma como de un
cuchillo de un filo algo que tiene una
punta y lo he puesto el agudo pues va a
ser lo obtuso algo que es grande o ancho
es la terminología en general para
diferentes tipos de ángulos menor a 90
grados son ángulos agudos iguales a 90
grados son ángulos rectos mayores a 90
grados son ángulos obtusos y si el
ángulo llega a 180 grados lo llamamos
ángulo llano